[Applause]
your
introduction was so uh exciting that you
scared your dog
oh douglas well he's a rescue he's
scared of everything
it's in his nature poor thing got like
you know
he he has a past don't we all don't we
all
right i have to tell you
that last night i played your game
and i don't know if the control room is
ready for this but we've got i mean
they're ready for anything but i have
yeah that's me
um okay good look at you oh yeah no i'm
playing the game
and um i also did the instructions
um where i don't want to spoil anything
but you
you say to go put something somewhere
and i did that
and i got i got through a lot and i j
neil okay first of all oh here's another
shot this is my game closet
at home and this might sort of give you
a sense of
we like the game why games are so
important to me
oh nice so now are those games you buy
and never play
or are those games you've actually
played no we're big gamers in the house
i mean
when i was younger or single i used to
have you know
fun parties with a bunch of adults and
play games
but now it's definitely more me and my
kids
this is why this is why i created box
one for
game closets like that because i like
you love the games and i would go
to a store and i'd go straight to the
games even like a bookstore one of those
giant
you know like in union squares oh yeah
and i
and i would go straight from the books
to the game section i would see all the
games and i thought they were great but
most all of them were
for groups of people two to six i love
me some scrabble
you know but i can't play it by myself
because i cheat
but but i thought wouldn't it be cool to
make a game that's a party game
that's only for one person that you can
play by yourself in fact that you're
supposed to play
by yourself and i also love the
idea of when you start playing a game
and you think it's a singular thing as
you're playing it the game kind of
evolves
into something that you weren't
expecting like instructions
like you said you're supposed to take uh
you're supposed to follow instructions
to the t
and you and you're supposed to take a
card and put it somewhere that you
normally wouldn't put a card
to make sure that you're paying
attention i want to make sure that you
just you are playing this game alone
and i love this idea for a game is to
have
a game that you can do if you're a
student if you're
in a dorm room by yourself if your
spouse is away for the day if you're
you know live alone if you're single
everyone is
by themselves at some point in their
week or whatever and
most people like games so i created box
one it's not what you think it is and
you i love that you said i'm not gonna
spoil anything
because it's a little hard to pitch
because i also love
escape rooms and i love the idea of
like a narrative within a game i know
that sounds strange
but you haven't you haven't completed
box one have you
no i haven't but i definitely had
questions along the way of
how did you come up with these layers
and one of my favorite games used to be
um why am i blanking out on the name
oh my gosh i can't even believe it it
had everything
in it um why am i blanking out cranium
cranium thank you ah thank you it was
like hangman exclamation and
pictionary and everything and that was
always the game i wanted to play because
it wasn't just one thing
and that is definitely not a game you
can play by yourself
and i play solitaire
i'm on my scrabble go app like a maniac
and i just i'm such a gamer and i always
have been like i used to be a
master solitaire player like i almost
won every time and i was like and i
never cheated
solitaire but i find i find solitaire
sometimes it's a little solitary right
we live in this
we live in a world now where we're all
in isolation a little bit so i wanted to
make sure that you're not playing the
same type of game over and over you
showed the cards part of the game
it evolves from that in a way that's
kind of interesting and this is all
from my own love of games my love of
immersive
entertainment my love of escape rooms as
i said before
it's really in love with this talent
it's real that's what i was like
thank you and it took a long time
yeah a couple years it took to to do the
whole thing and i did it myself i'm a
little to be honest i'm a little annoyed
at not you but uh there's some guy
online
claiming that he helped design the game
and i'm getting like emails and texts
from people there's a guy named
martin maloney or something like this
who's claiming that he
was involved in box one yeah a little
like frustrating to the point of almost
wanting
me to get litigious i probably just
shouldn't even be talking about it
live on your show or else it gives him
more credibility
i take pride in the fact that this is a
thing that i created and i like talking
about it this is why i'm on the show
with you
not to profit from it but to
legitimately have people experience
a fun super cool evening
day of a game that trust me
is not starts out simple and winds up in
a larger
kind of epic scale if that makes any
sense and i can't tell too much about it
or else i spoil things
no you really do i i and i and it's it
was it's very challenging it's like
there's a lot of intelligence a lot of
imagination
a lot of action and you're a fan of
escape rooms it just builds and builds
i was i've never really seen anything
like it as a true gamer and i was blown
away
at its uniqueness it's cleverness it's
it's it's really i mean it's this is
going to be
smiling from ear to ear because you have
no idea what still is and by the way i
woke up
to raymond a gentleman who came up to me
was like there's a guy
and i don't know some country who's
acting like you but he's
really disgusting and doing garbage
stuff and you should be aware of it so
there's always someone out there doing
something weird
and maybe he and your guy can get
together and do a whole party
um now your birthday no
we're here in cake week and i have
to before we go to commercial throw to
your cake
the robot versus princess cake neol
as if you're new i did this for our kids
a few years ago
my husband bakes cakes he's a he's
amazing david
he's like the chef in the family but i
get to sort of decorate them so this
year we did yeah
harper wanted princesses and gideon
wanted legos
and so i said okay we'll make a double
cake and it'll be legos versus
princesses
and they will be attacking you it's like
three rooms with a bridge
i think the kids were six i was it was
my it was i was in a very banksy stage i
was really trying to
take art to uh a subversive
level i don't know that it was healthy
for the children to see
robots and princesses destroying each
other on the top of the birthday cake
but
i enjoyed it you and david are such good
parents in fact i have a little david
story we're going to go to commercial
and i'm going to tell you about it we'll
be right back he's here do you want me
to get him oh yeah please do all right
we'll be right back everybody